what are you doing here in summer go
anyway honestly my mom won't say it but
we're completely broke any on this thing
that's left in our name this is creepy
old farmhouse our grandfather left us in
the middle of an hour
why'd you bring me up here entertainment
value what is that
[Music]
somehow a town that isn't anywhere near
a tectonic plate that has no fault lines
no fracking no loud music even is
shaking on a daily basis
I remember that one summer we died on
our table
I found this in my living room Oh killer
replica a replica of what a ghost trap
[Music]
there hasn't been a ghost sighting in 30
years New York in the eighties it's like
The Walking Dead
your dad never mentioned this team it's
just my mom
my grandfather died my mom says we're
just here to pick through the Rob loves
life
women
[Music]
who are you
call it a
[Music]
call it lock
[Music]
call it karma
[Music]
that everything happens for a reason
come on darling
it has a connor seat
[Music]
[Music]